continuing the run of people who i adore
and i say that even when they're not on
hold to hear me introduce them on the
rich eisen show
one of my favorite people um and not
just because he's supremely talented
he's also engaged to be married now life
is great for this man because he's also
reprising his role of randy reed
unless wait a minute we've never seen
him and randy reid in the room same room
at the same time
he is one of the greats eric stonestreet
back here in the rich eisen show how are
you mr stone street
hi buddy
how are you doing
i'm good that was such a nice interview
or i mean such a nice intro my pleasure
i want to give it i want to just tell
everyone how i feel about you um so uh
where do you want to start with this one
how do you feel about your chiefs right
now you got to be feeling good right
what do you think what do you think rich
i've said many times i go into every
season feeling the exact same way
confident excited
uh feeling like we're gonna win the
super bowl and it feels that way again i
think our i think our team is deeper
uh than the team that won the super bowl
deeper than the one that lost the super
bowl deeper than the one that should
have gone to the super bowl uh the year
before before before so i'm feeling
great man we've got a heck of a roster
what makes you think they're deeper eric
well
uh our offensive line is is is deeper
we've finally you know
loved love me some brett beach but we've
finally got an interior line and backups
yep you know quality backups i mean you
know i love fisher which fisher was
still our left tackle uh
you know his injury happened is exactly
the wrong time for him and for a city
that grew to love him but you know we've
got zeus over there now so i'm feeling
great about that
our right tackle we got quality right
tackle and remembers who fought his butt
off last year to be a right tackle after
we lost mitchell schwartz and now we've
got lucas niang who's the rookie kind of
but
not really who's doing great and then we
go to trey smith
i think maybe will come out as one of
the best if not the best draft choice of
the entire draft i think he said all pro
guard waiting to happen baby
i love it i gotta tell you man um the
home schedule for the chiefs and i know
you're
you're a season ticket holder there
um
this is like a who's who of the nfl man
i mean browns obviously we know chargers
bills
um the giants are coming out on monday
night you got the packers the cowboys
the steelers
i mean
holy crap i mean like
it's it's a it's a who's who but it's
also big
huge tests
with the chargers too who i think are
going to be vastly improved
this is good we say that don't we say
that every year
i mean come on i
thought we just say the chargers you
know the team to beat the afc west and
then chargers gonna do charger stuff i
mean look i love their quarterback i
think he's great but
ah
i like my chiefs
broncos defensive backfield i've
understand i've been watching that a
little bit it's great but i just love
watching all the other teams in the fc
west gear up to have to beat us that's
that's a new paradigm switch for me
right usually we're the team we were the
team of my childhood that was always
doing what we needed to do to try to
beat other teams well now what teams are
teams are doing what they need to do to
try to beat us which is a great place to
be uh we got great wide receivers we we
kept four tight ends jody fortson
just a stud in camp blake bell the bell
dozer oklahoma's bell dozer noah gray i
mean i'm sorry a four titans lineup in
that preseason game uh in a preseason
game when you know andy reid's not
playing showing his real play with four
tight ends right so uh good luck i mean
i'm sure it can be done the other team
on the other side are also professional
athletes but i'm here to see you cover
that
you know what it's interesting eric
stonestreet here on the rich housing
show you talk about the different
paradigm um you're gonna have to help me
with this one because tony romo who's
rarely wrong i mean the guy calls his
shot he even said after the chiefs beat
the bucks in the regular season last
year i think you know maybe we'll see
these two teams on this turf for the
super bowl later on this year nobody was
saying that tony said it and he was
right
he said that zach wilson of the jets he
said zach wilson of the jets
has such a high ceiling he sees the fact
that he could be a top five quarterback
in the next couple years
just he looks like mahomes
is what he said
and i don't i don't know how to handle
that eric i don't well
that's what i'm saying like can you help
me
like um
you know where you put all your hopes in
this person and he actually does become
that like how like what yeah what should
i look for how do i handle something
like that eric do you have something
when i say this i'm getting i'm getting
chicken skin and teary eyes thinking
about it for you
i mean you are bringing me back to when
the realization hit that brett veach
and the chiefs drafted our franchise and
we had him on our roster when i started
hearing stories about training camp from
some of my friends the things he was
doing and then when it came clear we
were really willing to deal alex smith i
i know what you're feeling right now
here's what i would say to you as a long
time fan of a team that has disappointed
you yes
hold tight
steady
steady rich okay
and you'll know when you know okay
right it's gonna happen
it's gonna be the moment that you and i
shared during the baltimore ravens game
when it was third and 38 and
mahomes hits tyree kill for 39 yards and
you're like
[Music]
i know right i mean because again eric
um
i feel like we have a you know a lot in
common and uh you know uh love of family
and lucky to have the jobs that we have
and you know i i found the the woman
that i love a while ago you you and
lindsay are now engaged we're we're
there now together there
i need to be together with you on the
generationally talented quarterback that
changes everything around i need to be
there eric with you i know i need that
i've been so close
i'm pulling for you i i would love i
would love it for you you're thank you
you deserve it you and new york deserve
it i can't imagine it doesn't go no eric
they don't deserve it oh you don't
actually deserve it
i want you eric though first off
congratulations your engagement buddy
thank you thank you thank you i want you
to just say you're going 20-0 like i
know you want to do it and we all want
you
to to be that guy just just say it like
we're going 20-0 no
i'm not gonna do that to anyone
let alone myself look
the nfl is the the the regular season is
a long road to hoe we don't have to be
20 you know we you know the truth we
only have to be 1-0 at the end of the
season exactly and that's in the that's
in the big game right so
we have the team to beat a lot of other
teams i'm excited the chiefs are excited
like i i they have so much fun
uh with each other in my experience
being around the guys that's all that
tone
that playful work ethic is all set by
our beloved andy reid he sets that tone
of like gentlemen it's time to get to it
but let's have some damn fun while we're
doing this right um
i love that aspect about my team their
pranksters their jokesters and uh but i
won't say 20-0 that's patrick's call i
love it he can actually do something
about it i'm just a fan i can't do
anything about it don't worry brockman
eric is just trying to steer the
conversation away just in case i was
going to go in the direction which is uh
cam newton re-signs of the team he likes
that they draft mac jones he's like why
are we drafting somebody when we've got
the guy like why would they do something
like that not what i said absolutely
yes and now he's all mac jones is the
next brady now he's all the way in like
he's all
the way in on mack jones but i don't
have any other choice
well yeah you don't it's true i mean
he's got to do what he's got to do i
figured you were a buccaneers fan by now
why i do i'm still on brady keep winning
that's totally fine
yeah of course you would be and by the
way
chris you've got to root for the chiefs
because if the chiefs make the super
bowl here in los angeles the super bowl
party the super bowl party at eric
stonestreet's house is gonna be what the
kids say live
right
right we miss your christmas party
we gotta come back
it's gonna it's gotta make a comeback
the super bowl party at stone streets
that would be it can you believe that
i would love it if we're in the super
bowl in l.a that would be incredible i
haven't been in la in a year but i mean
i'd love to come back for that
rematch just run it back
all right let's get into it uh the the
randy reed character is as great as ever
so you went to training camp again and
and uh and
and and got around there and and had
your fun with them walk walk me through
that whole process for you well you know
this started it started three years ago
and i did it just i've only done it
twice i've only you know and coach has
asked me privately to do a couple things
for the team off the grid that i've done
but you know listen it's my contribution
as trying to keep things fun i mean
that's that's what i'm that's what my
goal is here veach called me this year
and he's like are we bringing randy reed
back and i'm like well you know last
time i was there we won the super bowl
so i think you know what uh what we were
missing last year so that kind of was
the premise of it is last time i was
here we won the super bowl and i never
got my super bowl ring so we jump off
there and look the guys love it i
wouldn't be able to do it if coach reed
wasn't coach reid and gave his blessing
and approval and access to everything a
lot of people can't believe that happens
but they got a team there rob albarino
is the new vice president of
communications he embraced it we've
never met before he's like let's do this
and they rolled out the red carpet for
us my co-writer jerry collins who's an
incredible guy written a lot of stuff in
la and he comes and helps me with that
and then we had a new guy i just got to
get their names in here and
who edited this thing he he just killed
it they all killed it the chiefs killed
it and the goal is
just to have a little fun with the
players they genuinely
are confused rich you would be so happy
to be a little fly on the wall to see
the rookies who have no idea who i am
and then what my capacity is with the
team you would have so much fun watching
the new guys that are free agents that
are in camp derek mckinnon had one of
the best moments of the trading camp it
didn't make it in the cut but i walked
up to him with the thera gun on the
sideline he is sweating he's out of
breath he's drinking a glass of water
and i walk up and i nudge him with that
thing while it's on i said hey you need
this and he looked at me
he looked down at my face on my ankle he
looked back up at me and he's like no
man i'm good
he was so confused
i tell you man that was one of my
funniest moments uh the funniest moments
just
like them catching tennis balls with the
the machine that throws tennis balls at
him yeah and me jumping in there trying
to get into like cutting in between
these guys like
genuinely confused what's going on and
then the the veterans they uh they're
like hey you got anything you know you
gonna say anything to me the coaching
staff they're all interested this year
you know made sure we got spags the
enemy tobe
and everybody included
uh you know it's just a fun thing i
don't know that it'll last forever it's
just my little love letter to the chiefs
so i can't bring much to actually
winning but i can bring a little fun and
lightheartedness to training camp
fantastic it's fantastic i mean we just
showed some while you were telling those
stories some uh some video well without
the sound it's just you parking in
vicha's spot with the uh with the with
the huge golf cart now what was the one
with mahomes coming from behind and
stealing the town what was that one that
that one i hadn't seen well i was
i was talking to the offensive line
about you know the technique that i had
told the team about last time which was
kodiak which is
low man wins a lot of times but also
tall man scares other guys away so i
want the offensive line to get up and
big tall like a kodiak there so i was
going through that homes comes up and
steals my towel and takes off running uh
we we ended the clip before i uh ran too
far because they look so pathetic
all right we gotta cut out of this
before i look too embarrassed then the
embarrassing the taking a knee and
stretching two behind two oh my god
that is just so
funny and i just love the fact that
reads into it like that the actual andy
reid is into it he loves it yeah that's
great look i mean here's the deal coach
is like
i you got this amount of my amount of my
time i would never want any chiefs fans
or anyone out there because they're you
know i'm as big of a chiefs fan as any
other person
my number one rule is i don't want to be
in the way i don't want to take anything
away from the job at hand so coach gives
us a very limited amount of time that we
have to get his stuff done he's into it
he loves it he's welcoming and loving
he's a great i love him to death
and then otherwise it's there's just a
couple rules stay stay out of here stay
out of there i'm mic'd up just go out
there and kind of
kind of have fun but man i gotta tell
you dude there was one one moment that
didn't make the cut either yes where one
of the defensive ends was like man i'm
so confused who who are you like what
are you doing here
and one of you i think frank clark says
man that's randy reed you don't know who
randy reed and he's like no
and he was so out of it so finally i
said hey man my name's actually eric
stone street i was on a show called
modern family for 11 seasons and he
stops in his tracks and he goes
are you serious and i said yeah he goes
man i used to watch that show
religiously and i'm telling you what
the other defensive lineman bust up
laughing saying you used to watch it
religiously like religiously huh so that
was the moment there i it just the dawn
of the realization of i'm not a coach
i'm not part of the team in any way i'm
there literally just a clown around is
so fun to watch happen eric i love it
it's it's funny it's just funny for
everybody to watch too and it's just
great to see the players get get into it
and andy hey look when andy reid uses
his phrase the time's yours and it's in
your direction to have fun with
everybody the answer is yes every single
time i'm sure so that's great well you
know the organizations in the nfl they
they get a bad beef on so many things
you know but the not fun league and blah
blah blah blah blah blah whatever and i
just love that the chiefs are my team
and they're also a team that's willing
to like have a little fun
and poke you know get a peek behind the
curtain a little bit
uh i'm very respectful of everything and
how everything goes but um
i just love it but i i don't know how
many uh how many more years um
randy reed will make an appearance i
guess he's
he's got a he's gotta move on at some
point yeah he's gotta go he's gotta go
boating right he's gotta go on a boat
right he's gotta go what is it well now
i'm into drones too i can set you up in
a drone uh i can get you into drones
drones are the future
that's what it was jet skis before
that's it right oh man yeah now it's
drone all right last one for you have
you been on a a royals minority
ownership zoom with mahomes has that
happened has that happened yet no no no
we haven't we talked about it a little
bit i don't have i don't i don't have
much to say or much to do you know i
just
i mostly i just continue being a fan and
and i'm happy to have been able to
invest uh in in the mahomes is now my
home now owns he's part ownership of a
whataburger deal he's got ownership in
the kansas city girls soccer team here i
think sporting kansas city the royals
i'm like jiminy christmas i i gotta up
my game of ownership so you're not
you're not storming in steinbrenner
style demanding mike wit's kid gets at
bats right now
you're not doing that
no
i'm not doing that i don't want any of
that responsibility
uh so that's funny though oh man
dude i i i i i miss seeing you i haven't
seen right back at you
over a year been too long we'll do it
whenever you're around and so is there
anything you want to tell me about i
know you're up to a ton of stuff when
when do we see you on television other
than just watching well i got the show
domino masters it's coming out in
january okay got that i was out in l.a
for a month shooting that that's going
to be epic everybody's kids are going to
freak out over it mine will it's so neat
it's so competitive it's a chain
reaction rude goldberg domino show where
these engineers and of people that
design these amazing builds and they
have to do it in 16 hours but i'll start
doing press for that and come back on
for you and then um great that's about
it man i've been loving my life in
kansas city i can't believe that uh
you know i was in la for so long and i
came back here and it's been such a
blessing to be around my parents and my
family and
just doing my thing here and it feels
good i'm about to turn 50 and i'm
engaged i finally pulled that trigger
yeah we look at it but i love the
photograph you put out of it and i don't
know how she puts up with you man with
all the times that you you you you take
pictures of her on instagram when she
doesn't know that she's on or she's i
mean you you and lindsay are just great
to watch that's great i couldn't be
happier
people were saying i look like her dad
i'm like 39 years old like she has
nine-year-old boys uh how can i uh and
she's 40 she's gonna be 42 years old i
can't help that she's beautiful and i
can't help that i look like a grizzled
mind
i'm not going to say 20-0 but i'm going
to say a lot and oh of wins
though just just a quick prediction i
mean while like there you go like you
got it 15 and two what do you got you
want anything 15 and two i'm not saying
anything beach is listening visas texted
me while i've been on the phone
brett get out of here stop sliding into
his text while we're trying to get him
and put some bulletin board material up
there
i'm not gonna be locker room material
take care of yourself eric we'll chat
soon man i love you guys right now you
guys see you soon
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here